thanks everyone for joining us today
we're going to go ahead and get started
hope everyone got a chance to have have
some lunch
so yes today we're gonna have a series
of different talks and then a panel
portion of this session as well the
general topic is recommendation and
learning to improve personal
productivity or in other words Brecon
amazing recommendation and learning in
privacy sensitive areas over personal
data enterprise data and so forth
the rough structure of the session is
going to be I'm I'm going to introduce
some of the applications and areas that
are of interest to Microsoft some
research that we've done and then we
have three distinguished guests that
will speak on research related to these
areas so for those that don't know me
I'm Paul Bennett I'm a researcher here
at Microsoft Research and I lead the
information and data Sciences team we do
a variety of work at the intersection of
what I consider information science and
data science and then we collaborate
with other groups in Microsoft Research
quite strongly like Ryan White's
knowledge technologies an experience
group and amidala Dallas group language
information technologies in particular
in these in these domains as well as a
variety of product groups in this space
as well so let me just start off with
the notion of the personal web and most
of us are familiar with the global blood
but we haven't really thought about what
is the personal web and what does it
look like and the reason why we haven't
thought is because often there's not an
explicit structure but we all act with
it every day so for example you can
consider somebody who is currently doing
something on their device right and in
fact what they might be doing is working
on a Word document as they're working on
this Word document they may save it to a
folder right and as they're performing
these activities you're learning
something about the structure of the
world so the Word documents are I mean
word is used to work on documents it's
saved to this particular folder then
they get an email they switch to email
this email is from some other person and
that has an attachment it they saved the
attachment to the same folder so now
we've learned a little bit more about
the structure of their world they have a
question about this attachment the
reading and they go off and they search
for this on some search engine
being Bing will naturally come back with
the answers and as they're reading it in
the browser they may paste that answer
back into the document now they might
get distracted while they're on the
browser and go off and do some social
networking I know it probably doesn't
happen to most people here but I've
heard this happens and eventually they
might come back into return to this task
it might be on the same device it might
be on a different device now they open
up an attachment in the same folder and
the question is what do you know about
this their world if you were to help
them how much you help them so for
example if they were going to write an
email who would they most likely write
an email to if they were going to open
up another document which document would
be right so there's a lot of information
latent in the structure of their
personal web that is implicit in these
links and quite often we miss even
saving those we don't keep the
provenance of the information that this
webpage was where the material was
sourced from and if they open that
document again they might want to get
back to the webpage so thinking through
some of these recommendation and
learning scenarios there's a question of
how do we bring this type of information
together with all of the information
they work with whether it's from the
global web or personal web and enable
them to perform the task that they want
to do more generally how I like to think
of this is in terms of contextually
intelligent assistance people are
working in order to do something and
likewise when you're doing things for
your personal life as well so for
example I'm researching a trip right now
I have a particular task in mind and I'm
choosing apps in order to do that but
the information across those are
connected and so if we think about
providing assistance that says how do we
proactively bring to your attention the
information you need at the right time
place in context so for example if I
went to this web page that you would
actually say hey this is related to this
email that your spouse just sent you and
in fact they've commented on what they
think about this this would be an
opportune time to bring these things
together but we're keeping these siloed
according to how the apps live so how
would we learn and create scenarios
around this to take one view of this we
can look at how this happens in just
email itself so email has a rich lens
into somebody's life both personally and
professionally
you can take a lot of different
items beyond simple communications one
of the key things that has our items to
do and so you could look at how do
people actually say when they're going
to do something what requests do they
get how do they act on those things so
here's an example of an email right for
those of you who have communicated with
me you know that sometimes I write too
long of emails and this is an example of
one and within this I said that I was
going to do something right I said I'd
share a particular deck with other
people on the email thread probably
because the length is email I forgot
that I said I would do it and so the
question is how do you actually even act
on the things that you said you're going
to do so Cortana has a feature with able
to detect hey it looked like you were
able to do something by analyzing the
email I can tell that you've done
something do you want to act on it or
have you and if you've already acted on
it great you get to check it off and you
say look I'm happy I'm done with that
otherwise it's an implicit reminder of
what what you need to do so this is work
that Ryan White Erik Horvitz and I
collaborated with folks and product
groups in the MSA I product group and
Cortana in order to put this into
production but the interesting thing is
how does it actually look at your
content and turn that into something
actionable in terms of what it allows
people to do in terms of memory we go
from explicit reminders to having from
implicit reminders potentially a hundred
times more surface area of where we can
interact with people and say what you
should act on some of the
characterization of tasks that happen
over reminders pairs and to papers for
people one look at it work that Ryan
Eric and I did with David grouse a
former intern of ours at you map and
then Ryan
ammad and Robert sim have a paper coming
out just next week that's a guy are
where they look at how people actually
complete tasks and act on those so it's
a good understanding of how people
perform in their daily lives
now what are the some of the challenges
from a machine learning point of view
well there are billions of emails in
order to actually analyze every email
you have to deal with a tremendous
number of latency constraints there are
also other forms of communications there
are teams messages there are calendar
items there's a lot of other things you
have to serve these things at very low
latency partially due to the number of
messages but also because when you get
into
an interactive loop it turns out that
there's a trade-off between relevance
and latency the longer you take people
just ignore your attempt at assistance
because you're really just getting in
the way by taking a long time so their
demands on latency there are also many
different intents that we've already
built models for but there's a question
of how do you identify more there's a
there's a final interesting case email
in some senses the in the easy case
because email is right once you don't
update it afterwards but when you start
building intelligent models over
documents or other things that you can
edit the question is when do you perform
the intelligent analysis after it's
saved when it's closed while the person
is doing it all of those have trade-offs
in both the amount of information
available your latency demands and what
you can recognize so there's lots of
engineering challenges now looking
forward research wise you could ask
questions of how do you identify other
intents so for example there are very
general intents like provide payment
send in vase delegate authority to do
something on a particular system and
these are things that we've been able to
pull out by using Canon and many methods
and actually aggregating across users
verb object pairs to kind of understand
what's going on but then there are
things specific to an area so for
example we know what academics might
tend to do like write a review or submit
grades but there are all parts of the
world that have niche areas where we
don't know what their key action item is
are and how do we understand how that
language goes to actions more generally
and we think about how intents go to
actions think about how do those
communications relate to other types of
resources so my files are not your files
so you might learn that when I get a
certain type of content I act on a
particular file but what is the way that
we can generalize and cross users and
there's two challenges one is the
privacy challenge the other is the fact
that simply I'm acting on different
objects so an example of this is you
might recognize that this looks like an
expense request but each enterprise may
actually have a different internal
system for how they handle expenses
which grounds out in a different URL and
when you try to aggregate these you can
one-way hash all those URLs but they're
not going to look like each other so how
are you going to do this now that you're
going to recognize that this is serving
the same semantic content and the
language is grounding out in the same
basic action and so when the new person
comes into your organization and can't
find the expense system you might be
able to recognize the language but tying
them to the action and helping them on
port is still challenging other cases
where this comes up oh I forgot to
mention in this case so there was paper
next week at Cir we're a few way
weighing cigar has say any cigars in the
back there will be giving the talk next
week looking at how we identify a
variety of other intents from email as
well as use the full context of email so
other cases where we look at contextual
intelligence are things like meeting
related recommendations so suppose that
you want to prepare for a meeting this
is again a real example Devere aspirin
is a student at Carnegie Mellon right
now she's working with Christo's loose
dose and right now she's working with me
on some cases of analyzing productivity
related data we had a meeting Friday I'm
flying in from an international flight
and going straight to the meeting to
meet with her before the end of the week
and I'm not caught up on things I don't
know what's most relevant she sent me a
variety of emails these are not the only
ones but when I click on the calendar
items it's recommending to me what it
thinks is most relevant to be prepared
for this meeting and so what you're
thinking what you see here is that the
context is the meeting and by thinking
about how it interacts with these other
objects whether it's emails or documents
we can actually bring to someone's
attention what you really need to know
to walk into this and look prepared in
the shortest amount of time here we are
able to deal with some of the privacy
challenges by looking at the
similarities between the context the
meeting item and the thing that's being
recommended emails and documents and
aggregate across users in that way but
in other cases it's not so clear how we
would create a privacy preserving
representation and so our first priority
is always to protect privacy and so we
may not develop some features that are
conceivable because we're trying to run
this balance of saying how do we learn
across users and how do we learn from
individual behavior final example I'll
give the case of kind of making
suggestions as you're building slide
decks so I've heard stories that some
people when they're creating slides
actually reuse their slides they copy
paste I don't I don't know that this
really happens but it turns out office
has a scenario where they support this
the last one I shouldn't
was productize also by MSA i this is
being done by an office group he rockso
ml and and office itself looking at how
do we recommend what slides are relevant
in context so you'll know this this is
the usual slide this is a deck i'm
preparing the middle one is what i'm
working on and this is what might be
relevant to insert here and based on the
content of what you're currently doing
so here it's the slide that you're
working on that's the context what might
you want to pull in and experience this
and so as a little preview to let you
know that i do use our own features here
is the slide deck that i'm presenting
now you'll notice that the slide deck on
the right says research challenges at
the top right so you can guess probably
what's coming is let's talk about some
of the research challenges so uh so what
are the things that go on here i
mentioned this idea that you're
operating over personal information so
there are disjoint subsets that you're
dealing with and so if you think about
typical recommendation approaches like
collaborative filtering they're hard to
apply here because i can't recommend my
email and documents to somebody else so
what are the representations that we
couldn't learn across people likewise we
can learn just within a user but when
you learn within a user you have a data
sparsity problem how much data do i need
to build something that's effective how
do we maintain our privacy guarantees to
reduce when given that we have reduced
modern model builder visibility so
people can only certain see certain
things i can look at this feature and
say is it working for me or not that's
great if it's working for me I need it
working for all of our customers right
they don't do the same types of things
that I do how do we make sure that
happens
separating actions from goals I'll go
into a little bit more there and dealing
with data skews because these are both
sets of problems that there's some
progress in but there's a lot more
opportunity to you so just to raise a
few problems in people's minds we often
think about in the world of
recommendation that was a good idea if
you clicked on it but people's actions
are not their goals so for example I
might be working on a talk and as I'm
working on a talk I go wait it's been a
while since I checked my email let me go
check my email and see if there's
anything important there it turns out
there's nothing important there but I
get distracted by what's there I started
doing work and they go yeah I'm actually
working on this talk let me close email
and go back to this I repeat this
procedure now you're observing me
whether it's reinforcement learning
offline model whatever you will say hey
I
predictors are going to do you're gonna
go to email I can make that simpler for
you right I can make it less friction
for you to open your email and guess
what I will click on that now we
essentially have productivity clickbait
how do we get back to the case of saying
what are your goals and we still don't
have a good way to elicit from people
what their goals are how do we get back
from them whether they're satisfied or
not and this is ongoing work to
understand how do we measure this how do
we measure satisfaction in this space
all right so I'm gonna go through the
last part quickly to get to our speakers
last is if we think about what does it
mean to be a machine learning pipeline
so the canonical example it people often
think about is you design you do some
data collection you roll your model out
you know you have a runtime model
everything works you go have a party you
move on to the next project but this is
really much more like a lifecycle and so
you think about well within this whole
plan I'm going to be moving along
different steps and as I gather more
data I might roll something more bad
something out that's improved but along
this step what can go wrong in data
collection and learning for models so
the number one thing that goes wrong is
training data often doesn't look like
what it is once it's deployed now why is
that the case well it turns out you
didn't collect all your training data
from the entire world
ok that's simple I just need to correct
collect more training data well when
you're planning new features it turns
out there is no training data like what
you're deploying what you look at is you
look at log data from similar scenarios
so looking at slide reuse we know that
people open multiple slide decks at the
time we know they paste them in but it
turns out because of how they get to
them in different ways it will never
look quite like our scenario and so what
you're really trying to do is say I have
something that looks like that scenario
which has some presentation bias that I
don't know how it behaves because it's
not in the same way it's not an ice-rink
list I can't think about randomly
reordering my results but if I could I
knew how to deploy it to a global world
so how do we get past that problem and
then you know one of the more
interesting cases is this one this is
where we're best logged data from the
same scenario and the global
distribution once deployed now this
one's easy right
it turns out yes it's easier but there's
a lot of things that can go wrong one of
the things that we think about is how do
we deploy things so it's easy I just
scale it out right I have my set of
people that I test things with and then
I roll it out to a broader broader set
right and then ideal case everything
looks like the center and it's just a
matter of scaling it out more but it
turns out when you're working in these
areas the scale looks something more
like this so the inner thing might be
Microsoft and I'm testing it internally
and most of Microsoft may look like
similar sets of behavior there are these
weird blobs in there that look different
from each other and then the rest of the
world looks nothing like it some of the
other ones maybe these are tech
companies look a lot like it but a lot
of people behave differently so how do
you get insights there how do you get
feedback of whether it's working and if
they if your customers aren't working
directly with you
how will you instrument that in a way
that you know is appropriate in terms of
some of the biases that come up even the
similar scenario that are challenging so
besides the training data is not being
representative there's all sorts of
things so for example inventory change
even when you never actually changed
your model and you have the deployed
feature say you actually have a bunch of
things come online so you're you're an
enterprise customer you just acquired
another company guess what you just got
access to a hundred thousand files your
inventory just changed and now you have
no data over that from a point of view
of reweighed Attah you've never seen
behavior on that how are you going to
deal with those challenges so they write
a way in which things can go wrong
knowing about them discovering and
dealing with them or some of the things
that we look at all right so there's
also a whole white paper available that
Fernando Diaz and Emery catchman and
others talked about more general data
biases that I encourage you to read and
with that I'm gonna wind up there I'll
take one question and then we'll move on
to the next Baker's before the general
panel so
like there's a mic if you just wait just
a second
I'm just very curious about this ring
testing scenario you first go to your
dog fooding and then you go outside
further and further that's really
interesting if everybody is doing that
there must be some systemic failures and
you hinted at some of them could you say
more about that yeah I mean so um I
don't know at systemic so there are
different ways to get at that the
drawing is just one so for example in
other scenarios where social networks
are really used a lot more so for
example if your kids play pokemon go
Niantic that company just rolled out a
new game
wizards unite it was available first in
New Zealand why was it available first
in New Zealand because it turns out
their social network is isolated from
the world and it creates a great test
case where most of the links are cut off
and you can test independently depending
on your feature rolling out in rings or
rolling out in isolated bunches may make
more or less sense so if you're
depending on communication you better
make sure that you know if if me having
the feature depends on you having the
feature that has to be accounted for and
how you roll it up so the Rings are one
version of the world but there are other
world ways in which we think about
scaling those things out in individual
segments alright so our next speaker is
Jennifer Neville Jennifer is a professor
of both computer science and statistics
at Purdue and she does a variety of work
on machine learning specifically
targeted at graphs deep learning over
graphs and also has been looking
recently at student productivity from
instrumentation they have so that I'll
let Jennifer take it away I don't
I have my bag of dongles will travel
okay let's try this okay that works
so thanks Paul for having me here for
this panel I'm gonna tell you a story
today about my work with the people at
Purdue in the Office of Institutional
research so this is how you get faculty
to work for you you give them data and
you say I'll give you really rich data
said if you just consult for me while we
try to do these thousands of different
data science problems so some of the
stuff in this talk that will show up on
the slides is the official outcomes that
I can talk about that we've published on
but I'm also happy to take questions and
sort of talk unofficially about what
we're doing okay so probably starting
about five years ago Purdue started
coalescing the datasets that they have
around campus to try to create a large
behavioral data set that they can use to
analyze to improve students satisfaction
performance retention and so on at
Purdue this data that I started working
with specifically at the beginning with
them is data that they have on the
temporal and spatial behavior of the
students as they go around campus I
should state that differently they have
this data about everybody on campus
including the faculty the staff and the
students and what they're doing is
tracking all of your devices as they hit
the Wi-Fi and they have to resolve the
password to let you on the Wi-Fi they
can track which access points you're
going to for how long throughout the day
for your entire life that you spend on
the campus so we have very rich data
about what they're doing from their use
of Wi-Fi we have data from all their
different devices including the devices
that never leave their dorm rooms and we
also have data about the card swipes
that they use with their cards that they
pay for they get into the gym and they
pay for their meals at the dining halls
and the different cafeterias
and foodservice places and so from this
they have been collecting this data on
the temporal and spatial behavior for
about three years now and so it's a huge
massive amount of data and there's lots
of noise as uncertainty as an example of
the uncertainty sometimes you can show
up being in two very different access
points at the same time it's not clear
how the same device would be recorded in
two separate places across campus that
are not next to each other but somehow
that just goes into the data they also
have clearly have data on the students
and their activity and classes and their
performance over time but as more and
more of the classes use these learning
instructional systems like blackboard or
Piazza they have rich information about
how the students are actually engaging
in the system over time during the class
rather than just what they've submitted
and the grades on what they've submitted
over time so there are things like
discussions that they have feedback that
they get questions that they ask for as
they're doing homeworks in Piazza and so
there's a bunch of other faculty that
are doing like natural language
processing on the actual text of the
details of how these students interact
with these systems and then we have
information about the social behavior of
the students this is a little more
indirect because we and this is actually
what I'm working on mostly at this point
is that we're trying to infer who are
our friends with each other actually
based on the Wi-Fi and card swipe data
that we have above so there's no clearly
articulated friendship relationships
between the students we might have
housing information so we know who their
roommates are and how those change over
time as long as they're on their Purdue
campus but based on their interactions
over time and where people co-locate for
periods of time together we are trying
to infer who is friends with whom and
how those change over the course of
their life span at Purdue
so what we started doing and what I'll
talk about officially in this talk is
our analysis of this check-in data where
we tried to look at the temporal
patterns of where students went on
campus and try to learn a model to
predict when they're in a particular
place at a particular time we're to
recommend that they would go next and
the one thing I want to point out here
is that this type of educational
check-in data is very different than the
publicly available check-in data from
things like Foursquare or Yelp because
in those cases people are only going to
go to venues very infrequently so you
tend to go to new places to have dinner
or new places to see a movie and at
Purdue and the educational data you're
very quickly just going to the same
places over and over again and so we
have very dense visitation information
and we have very quickly people have
fall into a particular pattern of
behavior and so what's very different
here is the number of new POS POS our
place of interest I think is what it
stands for and so it's that the places
that they go to you can see that the
number of new places they go drops very
rapidly over the number of weeks in the
semester and so if we're going to learn
a model to suggest to people where they
should go based on where they've
recently been the target audience for
this at Purdue would be the new students
in their first semester because really
you're only going to help people with
your predictions in this range right
here where they're figuring out where to
go on campus oh I should go back here
and say this was just a density plot to
show you that most of the students are
spending most of their time in the dorms
this also actually was surprising to me
as we analyzed this but since we have
data for the entire 24-hour period if
you actually take into account the fact
that they're sleeping with all their
devices and their dorm rooms there's
actually a huge skew in the data towards
people being in dorm rooms compared to
say an academic building like the cs
building
so just in case you're interested in how
the data looks here is a comparison of
the temporal patterns of behavior
between the students who are computer
science majors and the students who are
pharmacy majors and what I'm showing you
here is the hour of the day and this is
a heat map so a darker bar means they
spend more time there and then these are
the different activities so we have in
the access points we have the buildings
that they're associated with and we
could go down to the granularity of
knowing which exactly is a classroom or
where in the building the access point
is but that actually would take extra
work to annotate it that way so what we
really have is just an overall
classification of the built the entire
building that they're in and so we can
categorize things based on residences or
places where there's recreational
activities like the gym and dining halls
oh I'm sorry
gym is separate here because that's a
separate building by itself so these
must be other places of recreation that
are not just the gym and then we have
places where there aren't classrooms so
they're primarily places they would go
to study including the libraries and
then we have classrooms and other in
other places on campus so you can see
that there's a little bit of a
difference between the patterns across
the different majors so maybe you can't
tell it in this version of the plot but
what's what is different here is that
the pharmacy students seem to be in
class in a much smaller region of time
throughout the day where the CS students
are spread across a larger range of
times and what was the other thing that
they did the pharmacy students also tend
to work out in a very regular schedule
so if you start to look at this very
closely it seems like the CS students
have a much more wider range of
behaviors because their classes are
spread over a wider period of time and
that the pharmacy students tend to stick
to very a more regulated schedule okay
so that was just a taste of the kind of
data that we have so in terms of the
kinds of
analysis tasks that Purdue wants to use
these data for is that they want to do
all the same kinds of things that all
big organizations would want to do with
the data that they have available they
want to use the predictions to make
better decisions to improve their
allocation of resources and specifically
to improve how they target the resources
to students and so specifically the the
one statistic that mitch Daniels the
president of Purdue wants to try to
impact is the time to graduation and so
most university settings they that's one
of their metrics that they try to
improve on and so what they want to do
is have more students graduate quickly
and by quickly that means in four years
and not longer than four years and so
that's really what they're focused on
and to do this what they want to do is
help to identify students that are
having problems and solve them more
quickly and also to give recommendations
to the students in terms of how to set
up their schedule and if they want to
change majors how to find a major that
is going to have the least impact on
their time to graduation if that's what
they care about
so specifically they sort of machine
learning tasks that I have discussed
with them and so either someone is
working on it or they're thinking about
how to work on it is that they want to
see in the social network behavior and
the temporal patterns on campus
they want to identify the kinds of
activities that seem to increase the
students sense of belonging and to
identify students that aren't engaged in
those kind of activities so that they
could suggest them to them more often
because one of the things that they
found is that the students are spending
more time on campus doing activities on
campus seem to be the ones that are
happy with their experience at Purdue
and also tend to stick around and
graduate they have
sorry I'm just trying to think about
what I can say with respect to this so
they have been doing analysis on the
difficulty of classes and the success
rates and the the impact on students
when they take certain sets of classes
together in the in the same semester to
try to make suggestions to the students
as to the difficulty level of the types
of classes that they have decided to
take in a particular semester and with
potentially the looking down stream to
their entire four-year plan and I'll
come back to this issue later when I
talk about the reaction to this from the
students and the faculty and then I
mentioned already that they want to be
able to identify the impact based on
changes in majors and so in order to
figure out this impact they have to
actually know the prerequisite chains
and the the sets of the logic that you
have to satisfy to get a degree in a
particular major and to be able to
calculate the distance or estimate the
distance if you're going to change from
say an engineering major to a computer
science major or from a computer science
major to a nursing major and that they
want to be able to give that information
to the students as they think about
changing their major I guess this might
be something specifically important for
Purdue because the students have to
declare their major before they get to
campus and so that's not something I'm
doing huh yeah so I think there's a lot
of students that come in with having
potentially picked the wrong major and
it's sometimes difficult for them to
think about how to change in a way that
doesn't make them take more than four
years to graduate then there's a whole
bunch of other kinds of tasks that the
administration would want to do to deal
with the load that we have recently
based on
the huge influx of students that we have
so we don't have enough housing on
campus in computer science I'm sure many
of you are familiar with this we don't
have enough faculty we don't have enough
classrooms so there's a huge increase in
the number of students and being able to
plan for that and figure out how to
allocate the classrooms and housing like
a year ahead of time and to know which
faculty that need how much hiring you
need to do they need to have a lot of
simulation and planning structure set up
and specifically what they would like to
do is to be able to do simulations where
they figure out if they let in another
five thousand students this is how we
keep the tuition constant oh I'm
supposed to stop I've run out of time oh
my goodness okay I haven't even gotten
to the good parts okay I'm gonna not
finish but I'm gonna go faster okay so I
will skip the detail okay so I'll skip
through this I want to talk about the
privacy issues here because this is
where we had some surprising reaction so
they when we started collecting this
data and we being Purdue started
collecting this data the students I
guess agree to the collection of this
data when they sign up for an register
for classes and when we started doing
this analysis I was very concerned that
everybody would sort of be up in arms
that we're using this data to make
predictions about the students and so
they had a town hall meeting or multiple
town hall meetings where they discuss
with students and faculty what they were
planning to do and actually surprisingly
the students cared nothing at all about
the privacy issues they just wanted the
results of all of these predictions
availed available to them as soon as
possible and so can you guess who had
the most complaints about the privacy
issues it was the faculty had the most
complaints and you know why that was the
case it's because they're actually we're
talking about this assessment of the
difficulty of the classes
and the faculty didn't want students
driven away from their classes because
they got a grade of being a difficult
class and so actually as you sort of dig
into it and I just was introspective
about it myself when I thought about the
analysis being done on me and my classes
I think that what happened is they when
the perceived benefit of the analysis is
great in which case the students thought
it would make it easier for them to
choose a reasonable schedule they
actually wanted to proceed with this but
the faculty felt that they were being
judged and evaluated in ways that they
didn't agree to to begin with and so
that actually killed this part of the
project okay wait I'm not finished yet
you can't stand that I'm gonna keep
talking I have a whole paper you can
read the details of this embedding model
to to do these predictions so I won't
talk about the details of our paper but
I did want to get to this list of
machine learning issues because Paul
asked us to talk about this and I think
a lot of them are very similar to what
you brought up so so I think that some
of the details and doing this modeling
that makes it very difficult to just
roll out off-the-shelf machine learning
methods are that you were combining data
from many different sources that have
many different levels of granularity so
this Wi-Fi access data is huge it's
every 10 seconds of every day of every
year that people are moving around
campus that's it at a very different
level of granularity than the students
grades at the end of a court of a
semester right and so that's made it
difficult to put everything together the
prediction targets are very difficult to
set up and I guess Paul talked about
this a little bit we have considered the
prediction of just where will you go in
the next time step or what will you
grade B in this course but in the long
run what we want to do is improve
people's satisfaction with their life at
Purdue and that's a very vague and
nebulous concept because you don't want
to just push everybody into the easiest
courses possible
so that they get high grades and are
happy with their life at that point
because some people need to be in the
hard classes to get through and actually
learn something in their degree and also
we have this issue with correlation
versus causation because they the
behaviors that we see in the past that
lead to good performance and good
outcomes are not necessarily behaviors
that if you tell another class of
students or another category of students
to do that that will actually lead to
good outcomes for them and so a very
simple and funny example of this is one
thing that they found very early on is
that they found that students who
registered early tended to do well in
their classes and so without any
consultation with people who know about
data science they started rolling out an
app to encourage people to register
early which of course is not gonna have
any impact on people's performance over
time right so it's just the people who
are actually diligent and will do well
in their courses who thought to register
early without the prompting and also I
want to point out that there's really
complicated trade-offs with respect to
students lives and the other issues that
they're dealing with while they're at
Purdue a lot of times the students that
are struggling our students who've come
in that aren't really prepared for the
kind of classes that they have to take
or maybe don't have the means to just do
classes and so they're working 20 hours
a week as well as doing all their
classes to try to support themselves and
so suggesting certain kinds of behaviors
that are unrealistic for them to be able
to achieve it's something that has to be
taken into account I have one more slide
let's take some of them in so okay I
will just leave it there and you can
read it
one question maybe about the slide Rock
Christ Chris is coming to the front and
switching over Thanks
I have this question that actually could
be addressed by the whole panel later
but which is about the privacy so you
mentioned that privacy perception by the
students faculty so first of I think
what I would consider what I would
characterize from the faculty is more of
a disclosure issue rather than privacy
it's sort of but but more importantly
the privacy thing because I've also done
this kind of stuff collecting data from
students and others and no matter how
much you tell them about what we're
doing and you know trying to be ethical
often people have hard time really
appreciating that issue of privacy and
so sure we have their permission to use
their data collect data from them but
I'm not convinced that they really
understand what the harm could be and
and so they're giving us permission and
this this risk goes to all kinds of
other services that collect this kind of
data and we all sign the Terms of
agreement and whatever and and I'm not
sure where this should be addressed in
terms of you know in academic kind of
setting in the industry setting but but
I think this privacy just because we
have that permission and we have done
all the right things from the IRB
standpoint to me it's still a little
iffy thing and and I think it requires
broader discussion then yeah absolutely
I agree with that one thing that I want
to point out here at Purdue one of the
reasons to do this analysis is that
there simply aren't enough resources for
advisors and sort of hands-on
interaction with humans and the and the
students right and so in this case the
goal of all this analysis is to target
those resources in the best way possible
and that's very different than somebody
taking your data and advertising to you
or you know denying you health insurance
it's not it definitely needs to be
discussed but I think that there's
actually different issues
here and I think the reason the students
were so excited about having this happen
is that they really are yearning for
that extra insight that they think is
there historically so right now it's
information that they get just from
talking to other students about which
are the good classes and when how should
I take them and I should take it now
because I might fail it and I need time
to take it again so that I can graduate
on time these are all things that are
being passed you know through personal
experiences right now and if that could
be codified in a way that it's available
to all the students I think that that
there's there's a case for a big impact
in that way which offsets some of the
potential downfalls but certainly people
are going to start seeing the downfalls
right so here's an example I think some
of this will come back speaker again all
right so our next speaker is Chris Rea
Chris's and associate professor at
Stanford and he'll be talking to us
about some of the ways that people are
thinking about broadening what we think
of as supervision and how people might
act on data in order to improve the
models of yeah awesome so one thing that
was in the pricey for this for this
session that was really exciting is
working on private data and in another
life as a result of an acquisition
actually work on another assistant Siri
and it's really an important problem so
I want to implore you that those first
problems about how you do machine
learning in private settings and places
where people really take it seriously I
think is a is a really interesting and
challenging question I won't talk about
anything from my Apple life I'll just
going to talk about Stanford work and
talking here just about how we have been
thinking about programming programming
by constructing training sets and I'll
walk you through why we started this
idea and it took off a little bit more
than we expected the reason I think is
honestly this cast of great characters
box at Brown Alex Ratner will be up here
in the Pacific Northwest sometime very
soon on the faculty of Washington okay
so here's the here's the overview of how
we got started
due to a first approximation you know
machine learning applications have a
model they have some training data and
they have some hardware and this has
really been kind of the sauce that's
powered a huge range of really exciting
industrial and scientific applications
well
we started to notice a couple years ago
that the model was kind of becoming a
commodity if you wanted the latest and
greatest model you could you know go out
to the wonderful people at hugging face
install Burt and it's like one line to
be able to get it oh you wanted excel in
that that came out last week well Tom
Wolfe just posted it on Monday and
they're off to the races you are with
the world's great you know greatest pre
trained model hardware at a second tier
cloud vendor you can get you know
instances whenever you want if this is
recorded at Amazon I still love you but
anyway so you know you can get instances
whenever you want if your system you
know needs a little bit more memory a
couple more GPUs well then I just I put
- - you know larger instance type and
I'm kind of off to the races and the
point is in a real way for developers
when they sit down to build a machine
learning problem
state of the art models and pre training
or even the architectures that are out
there are pretty readily available to
them as our huge amounts of hardware but
the bottleneck is that training data
usually isn't and so we started really
seriously thinking about why isn't
training data more of a commodity why
don't you have more stuff to effectively
start from and could we start to put
this problem on really formal
mathematical ground now that we this is
gonna be really high-level there'll be
no math in this talk whatsoever but
that's basically where we spent the last
three years of our lives so we started a
look at what people were doing in our
own applications and academia and also
in industry and we started to see that
people weren't taking training data that
was sort of you know the classical thing
you know when I the first lecture of
machine learning when I taught in the
spring you know X&Y pairs come where do
they come well they come from God
herself and then machine learning starts
but actually those X&Y pairs that we
care about actually are really coming
through processes people are building
them up in various different ways
and there's a lot of structure and where
those Y's are coming from people use
things like pattern matching distance
supervision you know data augmentation
taking their existing data and changing
it in cool ways topic modeling to figure
out this is actually one that's really
popular in a lot of the web companies
third-party models crowdsourcing and so
on and so these training points that are
coming in they're not really of equal
quality there are really radically
different quality and people were
applying these weak supervision and
techniques and kind of ad hoc ways and
so all we wanted to do is take all the
different sources that were out there
and be able to allow you to put them
into one framework and combine them
and that's what we spent our time doing
theory about okay so I won't go into the
details it's this project called snorkel
but it was just formalizing this
programmatic notion of labeling and
augmentation and something we call
slicing there's blog posts and code and
you know if you really care about the
details it's all online and so we
started building this up to try and
understand how we could combine all
those different sources of weak super
vision in one platform and what we
started to realize after we build that
is that's actually the dominant way at
least some engineers for some problems
we're approaching it
they weren't changing the model anymore
they were just changing the super vision
there are people in industrial settings
and I'll talk about a couple that never
write a code of a line of code of like
PI torch or tensorflow nothing at that
low level they only modify the training
data and monitor it over time and that's
a pretty exciting shift in computing
alright so how does this work just for
context users right they're labeling
functions or their augmentation
functions over here basically what
happens is we think that those
augmentations and those those labeling
functions are not of high quality or of
known quality we're gonna have to
estimate their quality we're also gonna
have to estimate their correlations so
that looks like two machine learning
people like estimating the parameters of
a graphical model the problem is we
don't assume that we see the training
data so the Y is unobserved its latent
and so we basically have to do structure
learning and parameter learning but
without ever seeing the Y so how do we
do that well because we have multiple
sources we actually get multiple views
on the same data and our basic theory is
about when you can do this and when you
cannot okay now once that's done once we
get the parameters of that label model
we basically create a probabilistic
training set so we generate a bunch of
points and then we assign to every point
a confidence if you like of how likely
we believe that point is accurate and
then we can put that into any kind of
downstream model if you want to get
really into the details you just rip off
the losses and make them aware that
they're being sampled stochastically
okay so this is the general framework
now the point is probabilistic training
data and no training data in the
conventional sense really needed but
this allows us to build applications
hopefully much more quickly and capture
what people were doing anyway without
any of that hand label data alright so
why the heck would you do this so I'll
give you three slides to overview why
this is not a totally insane idea the
first thing that you get is actually
improved gener
we actually have theory about this but
also practically when people use those
week supervision methods they often are
using very precise rules or they're
using kind of brittle code they have
rules that are laying around and they're
not able to take advantage of these
wonderful machine learning models that
allow them to generalize and capture
kind of the distinct patterns or the
linguistic variation where all the image
variation that they've seen and so this
allows us to get dramatically higher
recall in real applications both
scientific and industrial applications
okay this is just a slide basically
giving you an example of that someone
writes a labeling function maybe it's
like kind of a standard distance
supervision or a keyword based thing and
we get the synonyms for it kind of for
free
in this approach okay a second reason
and this is one that catches on
especially with industrial companies so
training data is a depreciating asset as
soon as you collect conventional
training data it's out of date we heard
in the you know in Paul sock at the
beginning you're always in this kind of
cold start problem and you're always
changing when you when you release a
product as soon as you release a product
and something starts working hopefully
users start to use it and your entire
distribution changes and so you're
constantly in this case where you've
labeled for the data you had or what you
thought you were gonna have
prospectively as Paul was talking about
and then the world changes out from
underneath you if the labels are all on
that old set you're toast
and so what this allows you to do is
basically take this unlabeled data and
pipe it through those functions again
and again and again even if it's
imperfect and so you see this kind of
nice scaling that as more unlabeled data
is coming in we're actually getting to
higher quality the last bit is touching
on this knowledge transfer issue again
this is something with Stanford Hospital
the details aren't super important but
basically the idea is we're trying to
build something that allows you to do
like a lot of folks look at a radiograph
and be able to diagnose certain
conditions the way this is typically
done is you sit down with a bunch of
radiologists you're actually a committee
of radiologists and they label those
those images again and again okay this
is important to do but that's a really
slow and expensive process now we do
have lots of radiographs with reports
from places that are laying around we
don't have those reports when the person
comes in because you use the radiograph
to write the report but we can use those
reports to supervise the image
classification so this transfer across
modality is quite
useful you have image you have data for
one purpose and you're able to repurpose
it using these weak supervision
techniques and again people have been
doing this for the last 10 or 15 years
but somehow we still maintain that those
x and y pairs are just falling out of
the sky and so we want to model that
process and then build tools around it
and that's what those folks did right so
to recap why you might do this and what
the differences are between manual kind
of conventional labeling and labeling
your first label and your last label
basically take the same amount of time
you don't get any speed up or scale it's
expensive you need people to do it and
as I mentioned it's static if you change
the classes you're after you introduced
a new feature then what are you going to
do with all that old label data you have
to be able to port it over in some way
for a new application and so in contrast
these programmatic labels there's a
little bit of time to be able to deal
with them but then as soon as you get
them in you can run dramatically faster
you run at the speed of like running
Python maps over huge amounts of data so
that's really exciting there hopefully a
lot cheaper because again we're using
the second tier cloud vendor if we just
use Azure it'd be like one cent an hour
so you can still run all of these
different things and hopefully it's
dynamic as I mentioned when the tasks
change you can repurpose training data
so to be clear that training data is
depreciating but hopefully not as
quickly as it was in the first case all
right so the last thing I wanted to
mention about what we're doing in this
thing is that we're trying to build this
analogy of now you're writing programs
to create data you can kind of think
about manual labels as the ones and
zeros of traditional machine learning
just like the ones and zeros of
traditional machine language and with
full analogy to the stack that you can
create from assembly language to
high-level languages and declarative
languages we've been tried to be
inspired by these to be able to create a
parallel stack on the supervision side
over the last three years and on the
blog you can go and check the different
papers that we've written well some with
industrial partners some with scientists
about filling out this stack so here I
talked about labels from code data
augmentation really this is still like
the low level of like creating zeros and
ones new pairs but you can do things
like take advanced primitives to do
these kinds of systems and combine them
that's a series of papers written by per
OMA where she uses these advanced
primitives to build these labeling
systems dramatically more
additionally things like synthesis fall
into this bucket being able to
synthesize examples we also have not
people who can't code we were working
with some neuroscientists they didn't
know any Python but they could write
precise English and we took that precise
English and we would basically translate
it using a first one of Percy semantic
parsers which was a great collaboration
Percy Lang to try and generate these
labeling functions from natural language
nearly automatically and then finally
and perhaps most crazily we've been
looking at things we're sort of
observational and this is where we get
into some of the things that I think are
really starting to talk about the
personal web and why I put this light in
here which is we want to learn from the
entire as we call it exhaust everything
that someone is doing when they're
interacting with the system leaves
behind some kind of digital trace we
focus on developers because those are
the folks that we have the most access
to but the personal web has very similar
kinds of characteristics you're clicking
here you're doing things what can we do
observational II what we're doing right
now is that Facebook basically gave us a
bunch of eye trackers and physicians
right now have switched their mental
model they love machine learning people
if you show up and say like strap this
to your face ten years ago they would
have punched you now they put it on they
wear it all around campus like they're
one of the cool kids so we get a lot of
data from this observational thing of
what are they looking at what are they
clicking on and we're trying to figure
out what we can do to learn from that
okay all right so check it all out it's
on snorkel I didn't want I didn't put
citations on the slides but they're
they're all in these book series of blog
posts okay all right that's the blog now
I feel obligated I like I really love
NLP people because they hate
leaderboards more than the vision people
the vision people love leaderboards the
NLP people just like snark about them
but they still show that you're actually
able to do something and so I like that
so you can actually get you know with
these training data first approaches you
know state of the art results at one
point on March 22nd we were number one
on this glue benchmark which were these
big multitask general language
understanding then Microsoft and Alibaba
managed to crush us mercilessly
afterwards
I will point out that Microsoft and what
they did which was really cool was they
used a lot more weak supervision on a
particular task called a Winograd schema
to crank it up and they're both sponsors
of the lab so we really loved them and
thank you so much for crushing us anyway
super glue no one seems to be really
submitting to super glue unfortunately
we are number one I'm not sure how
strong
statement that is right now at least on
July 1st we were I haven't checked
recently but the point is these are all
gains that you get from manipulating
training data and they're dramatically
higher than sort of things that are on
the pre-training side which is cool now
you may think this is something that's
confined to academia and from this pitch
that would be a pretty reasonable guess
shockingly our friends over in Mountain
View actually picked this up due to the
great work of a person at Stephen Bach I
should plug his work he's amazing he's a
professor at Brown if you see him he's
also extremely nice so go ahead and talk
to him he won't he won't bite you but he
basically went over there and we
collaborated in the lab to build this
version that they call snorkel dry Bell
which is running in production at Google
the feat pitbull who built it were all
from ads it's spreading people are more
people are using it we're really excited
to support it basically what they did is
take all the organizational resources
that they had internally and kind of put
them into that labeling framework that
augmentation framework and they actually
saw you know improvements as was
documented in a very recent paper and
blog post on the AI blog over there
about why this actually improved a lot
of their models and it had to do again
with this being able to transfer data to
different context in really interesting
ways one thing I'll mention is this idea
of servable versus non servable features
this is pretty interesting there's a lot
of times when you have great signal that
you've just aren't gonna have it test
time and figuring out that split is
super exciting and interesting all right
so I will I will finish programming
supervision is effective when we started
this we really have most people thought
we were crazy when I say we're gonna
program by supervision but I think
that's actually a really reasonable way
to do things and in fact people were
doing it that way anyway a second thing
is this idea of data exhaust is really
driving our work what are the weak
signals that are out there that we can
learn from and I think that's a really
exciting area for machine learning to go
in and especially some of these kind of
personal information sources that were
described in the first talk and the last
thing I'll say is check out the blog for
details someone has managed to use the
code who's outside the lab that's the
most that I will bounce for it thanks so
much
so you joined while you come up we'll
take one question for Chris as well one
here all right let me follow up with a
question myself then so one of the
things that you said that piqued my
interest was the getting non machine
learning experts to describe precisely
supervision using natural language have
you tried this with others outside of
like how many different fields have you
tried this with where people can specify
that's what they're looking that's a
really interesting thing so we tried it
with neuroscientists the other place
that is really exciting is inside the
law those folks tend to write precise
kinds of language and so we're really
excited over there actually the place
that that kind of reasoning has caught
on the most is inside kind of labeling
frameworks so big companies often have
huge fleets of labelers they're writing
a spec and those specs tend to be
actually in English and written in a
fairly precise way and sometimes there's
some transfer you can get from there the
question of how broad or narrow
applicable that technique is I don't
know and also ours was kind of like at
the stage where I would say you know
it's not how well the bear is dancing
it's that the bear is dancing like we
got some lift from it but we have no
idea how to expose natural language in a
better and more systematic way doesn't
seem to be showing here mmm so while we
get this one showing I should say we
pregame din lunch and talked about
extending talks a little bit cuz it
seemed like a lot of time for panel good
time for a few questions while we do the
rest of this is there that goods
and duplicate the right yeah okay I'll
turn off the help them before they come
so next I last speaker is Yujin Troy
Yujin is a professor here at University
of Washington she is both in the in the
linguistics and the computer science
department and she's gonna be talking to
us some about common sense and how we
bring common sense into our
interpretations of automatically doing
things with language actually maybe I'm
affiliated in the liquid linguistics
department as well but primarily 100
percent with the CSE okay so I'm going
to talk about something a little bit
different now this doesn't really work
so this question about personal
productivity requires also being able to
observe what people are doing and then
out of that so like we observe emails
and photos and videos and then we can
infer what people really want to do
there are intense and goals and emotions
and this question was one of the
important topics in post opening speech
as well and then out of that we wish
that motion and humans together are
going to act on some actionable things
soon enough so when we think about the
challenge at the first hand we have this
challenge of combining information from
different modalities and do some
reasoning over different modalities but
even more important challenge is to
think about the common sense
understanding of people people's actions
and events that happen to people so that
we can reason about what why they are
doing what they're doing and then think
about how to help them better so a lot
of emotion learning challenge is about
not having this common sense
representation of the people and then
get away with it
by just having a lot of labeled data and
then just learn datasets
we're task-specific representations but
that doesn't really hold in this case
because of the privacy concerns we may
not have the same kind of largest scale
training data that a lot of deep
learning models rely on today so can we
do something about this situation of
understanding people so let me give you
a little bit of operating definition of
a common sensor for now which we might
expand later but for now let's say it's
the basic level of a practical knowledge
and reasoning concerning everyday
situations and events that are commonly
shared by most people so it doesn't have
to be something that every single person
agrees on but it has to be something
that a lot of people agree on so for
example probably most people will agree
that it's okay to keep the closet door
open for some time but not as okay to
keep the fridge door open too long
because food inside might go bad you can
always come up with some weird situation
where this may not be true but by and
large this is generally what people will
agree on so people do rely on this sort
of understanding about the world in
order to act safely and then interact
with each other
pleasantly as AI becomes more and more
part of human lives it's important that
they I do understand how we understand
each other and our goals and emotional
states and first and so forth so the
word common sense by the way is a crazy
word a lot of people had this reaction
that why do you work on it it's just
impossible a lot of smart people worked
on it in the past it didn't work so
today I'm going to show you two pieces
of our work that shows an entirely
different approach that any of the
previous research has tried out and
demonstrate that it might work this time
around so it's war presented at triple-a
I this year with wonderful collaborators
including the lead Arthur Martin who is
doing internship at my store this summer
with Eric okay so here's the one really
good example too
about when you hear this event X repels
wise attack so for example I repel the
summons of taking a straight
what can you imagine about the situation
as a person we can immediately think
about a lot of the causes and effects of
that particular event it so for example
perhaps I try to repel someone's attack
because I wanted to protect myself so or
protect other people you don't know
which is true without additional context
but you can imagine that based on very
limited contacts this one of these is
likely to be true so this sort of a
reasoning is a stochastic it's not like
100% with the certainty there's a lot of
uncertainty however as a human we will
agree which of this is more likely a lot
of these other types of predictions have
to do with effects were post conditions
of the event it so for example if you
look at the bottom side maybe as a
result of my heart speed my trace where
I might feel angry or I might punch it
back some more and so forth so all these
events are potentially possible and
these are posted conditions and a lot of
these predictions are about dynamic
state changes whereas the some of these
are about reasoning about static aspect
of the world so for example you know my
personality doesn't change every few
minutes so if I'm the kind of person who
repels the summons attack probably you
know I may be someone whose skill the
fiscally were brave and strong some of
these inferences are about voluntary
actions whereas some of these are
involuntary reactions to the event some
of these are about X person X doing the
action whereas some of these inferences
are about the other person Y were other
people involved in the event so there
are different types of a hierarchy that
we can think about for any given event
so the purpose of this study was really
to address this concern about currently
deep learning is a lot about carb
feeling and then we don't really think
about causes and effects there probably
are different ways of
dressing this but what we tried to do is
one way to do that and we want fairly
crazy to collect almost 900 thousands of
this sort of if-then reasoning rules all
in natural language and how did we get
all of this so one could do unsupervised
learning or out of this unstructured the
text because there's a lot of texts out
there but there's a practical concern
that due to the reporting bias if you
count how many times people mother
versus people exhale if we just rely on
text then motion will think that we
mother four times more often than we
exhale which is unlikely to be true so
because of that although combining both
directions is a very good idea just in
this work we went entirely where the
crowdsourcing so that we can see what we
can possibly do if we have high quality
large-scale data so we had like 900
thousands of this and I'm going to now
tell you what we can do once we have
that for some reason this slide doesn't
really show fully hmm that's interesting
why is this broken
but anyway so what I'm about to show you
is now a new representation of a common
sense that builds on this graph that I
just presented and the work is going to
appear at ACL this summer so here's a
bit of a philosophical statement about
how to do this sort of like
largest-scale knowledge graphs about our
knowledge I will say that whatever we
did where the crowd is are saying it's
not going to scale up to match the
amount of knowledge that humans ever
have and in fact maybe we don't really
need to write down all of this per se
because if I asked you whether elephants
are bigger than butterflies you didn't
need to write it down beforehand in
order to answer my question correctly
you somehow have this model about the
world which allows you to answer this
question correctly so that's what we
really want to have in the
a model that can reason about anything
that it hasn't really exposed it to they
thought about before but still be able
to reason about it ideally in natural
language because that's the primary
communication medium among people so but
in order to get there it's likely that
we need to do some kind of a transfer
learning Chris was talking also about
knowledge transfer across different data
sets but we can also the transfer
learning across language and knowledge
or language and different data sets as
well which is what I'm about to present
so the goal is to have neural models to
train on part of the graph of the
knowledge and then be able to reason
about the rest of that it's never seen
before
and it's built on top of model
architecture known as the Transformers
Comet stands for common sense
Transformers in particular which
combines the representation of language
and knowledge such that now I'm going to
skip over or this modeling part and then
just tell you what kind of things it can
reason so it hasn't ever seen a sentence
like agian just to get the audience
attention before in part because the
graph is all about person actually doing
something to person why it's not very
compositional and it doesn't have a
people's name either but just because
these transformers have seen a lot of
unstructured the natural language text
before during its pre training and then
has been fine-tuned on the graph of
knowledge now I can actually reason
about this so you cannot see anything
right now but basically what happened is
that they're given up that title
sentence it can reason about a lot of
these common-sense predictions that I'm
going to now show you in more detail so
so very example maybe I did that because
I wanted to give a presentation it's
interesting that the event doesn't even
include the word the presentation but
it's still able to predict my intent to
being maybe I want to give a
presentation before doing that probably
I needed to be prepared for it and as a
result I may be seen as someone who's
done about smart about may be prepared
and determined
fact one person acts so as a result I
might feel satisfied the happy I don't
think I'm nervous but maybe some
presenters to feel nervous as a result
maybe I want to give a speech to be
heard yet the tension be noticed and
then I may get yelled at which hasn't
happened yet but I suppose I will
receive some feedback eventually so the
predictions are not necessarily perfect
but it's fairly reasonable I would say
Alex drives his sister to the mall for
example what happens well maybe he
wanted to be helpful maybe he wanted to
make her sister his sister happy he gets
into the car before handy he needs to
start the car he needs to have the car
he as a results will be considered to be
helpful caring and generous kind and
thoughtful these are again motion
predictions entirely not perfect but
fairly promising I would say considering
that this is just based on one paper so
far so it's able to predict them maybe I
wanted to
I will afterwards to feel happy helpful
satisfied others will also feel grateful
as a result and others may want to go
shopping and so forth how about another
example John gets into an accident maybe
he feels hurt scared upset that sounds
unreasonable it can perhaps he wants to
call 9-1-1 afterwards so it can make a
lot of reasonable predictions
common-sense predictions in language
which perhaps we can then map down to
some other programming style
representations for helping people to be
more productive so yet another one she
goes on a date with him maybe wanting to
have fun want to miss her man needs to
get dressed up first or make plans and
so forth alright so if you want to play
with this so there's online demo at
mosaic kg that EPS that Alan AI or J or
if you just search comment with my name
and then Alan AI you will probably find
this site alright so - as a quick read
we were thinking about this how to
improve a personal productivity and then
another challenge that I haven't talked
about is the multi modality but I'm
going to be very brief here it's about
work that we presented a civvy period
this year and if you imagine a
restaurant situation like this current
visual recognition works well enough to
recognize people correctly and a lot of
objects correctly but this really
doesn't make the machine really
understand what's going on in the scene
to be able to answer questions like why
is a person for pointing at person one
in this particular scene and here the
answer is because he's telling the
server the person one ordered that
pancake as opposed to other options like
he's feeling accusatory or giving
someone directions but you can imagine
that in a restaurant setting the correct
answer is this if it was in a meeting
setting maybe the correct answer is that
all maybe personal one wants to ask a
question and you want to draw attention
to that person so the correct answer is
all very contextual and this is sort of
like a challenge work that tries to
encourage the computer vision people to
think about how to do this sort of a
modeling better so currently human
performance is very very high whereas
our best model are to see which is a
recognition to cognition network is not
very good it's a 65 so a lot more work
to be done and this data set available
at visual common sense that comm present
about 300 thousands of this sort of Qi
questions about images along with
rational also that you have to answer
correctly so again I mean there's a lot
of there are a lot of important and
exciting challenges to address for
making this work and I although I didn't
really talk about privacy like how to
better address it due to the privacy the
practical implication of the privacy so
that we don't have the kind of data that
a lot of neural network based research
assumes to be available so because
that's not the
case we do want the machines to be able
to learn based on much less amount of
data which really makes these importance
of pre training model pre-trained the
models that can generalize across the
different situations and one really
important question that i want to
emphasize is how much can we get away
with our common-sense knowledge we're
not modeling people at all and perhaps
we can try doing more of it
with all these new resources about
crowdsourcing and your own network and
everything thank you so I mean let me
invite the other speakers back up while
we also take a question for you Jen -
Kristen so a question for you ginning
specific so let me go ahead and ask one
about the common sense so you think
about this kind of structure as
accelerating how much data we need to
learn so are there you know if you look
at specific tasks of where common sense
would help the most things like looking
at the next sentence somebody would
write or other types of things you have
a sense of where is big impact there and
sort of if we rewrite by common sense
where we see the largest impact right so
I would imagine that I mean eventually
one can always hope that if we have
extremely high quality common sense
model then it might help with anything
however that's not going to be the case
in all the ears so if we have a more
limited common sense model that for
example focus only on everyday events
then it's going to be probably more
useful for the kind of a task where that
sort of knowledge is important which
could be for example like human robot
interactions if the robot is operating
with language and vision based
communication with the people not
necessarily manipulation it's not going
to improve manipulation particular but
there are going to be also a series of
benchmarks that my lab is about to
release this summer some of them are
already in the public domain but there
have a winner so in
number of common-sense benchmarks coming
out from NLP field as well more broadly
so those will be sort of the first
target because those are good
approximation that really expands the
scope of what NLP techniques can
actually do a lot of a previous NLP
research focus on like tagging and
labeling and parsing but going forward I
think we can really expand the scope if
we push this direction father thanks the
thing that all the speakers again so for
then now abbreviated portion was going
to be a panel discussion of some of the
things I have a set of pre-prepared
questions but I also like to invite the
audience to ask questions as well so if
you have a question for the set of
speakers to answer kind of in
conjunction feel free so let's get the
mic over there while I go ahead and and
fire into the first one well I just one
second um so so one thing I mean the mic
that's fine one thing I did want to ask
sort of in general we think about this
space across the board of how we're
dealing with privacy either by reducing
the amount of data through common sense
or giving people other programming means
or may be the case in very personal
scenarios is that it's less about
privacy than really communicating what
the benefits are and and making sure
that we're thinking about all the
stakeholders whether they're students or
affect them more generally what do you
see is the research landscape to kind of
push that area further beyond sort of
just privacy based methods but thinking
about how we interact with people you
can keep your mics down too by the way
right so I mean he said that in order to
really catalyze the research into that
direction like Jennifer said earlier we
really like data they don't really
attract us to work on it and if there's
such data that's more about interaction
with the users which is really difficult
to get for people in academia without
the platform so
if there's something like that share
that that would really nibble on other
possibilities at least having some kind
of a simulation environment it's not
very satisfactory but on the other hand
you're so mentioned earlier about the
use of reinforcement learning for as a
learning framework but to be honest -
whenever reinforcement to learning those
who work is when there's a simulation
environment under which you can try
million trials in order to really learn
how to act but without it it seems that
the progress is very very slow all right
question over there okay this is peter
burtowski
i'm serving this year as a program share
of Rex's conference and there was
interesting thing that apparently the
erectus community is not considering
that recommendation and prediction of
the same things and here we're mostly
talking about recommendation the sense
of having a date and predicting what
people do and that's a pretty much work
like kdg work but in recommender system
community people are partners think that
it should be some value some usefulness
and you can very easily predict where
the person is going and egg p.m. to the
gym right and recommend him hey p.m. you
have to go to the gym which will be
completely useless Chris person will
know that right
so what do you think on your side
because working with data how you would
distinguish prediction from existing
data from recommendation make sure
Jennifer provided some great example
when predicting form the current be here
will be completely pointless right but
what is the take on this community how
we can turn our data and move beyond
just predicting but doing something
useful I guess try to take that so I'm
not so I guess maybe I'm from the
machine learning community that doesn't
see the difference between
recommendation and prediction but I
think if what I would like to say to
that is I think it comes down to
evaluating the results of your
prediction in the right way so like I
said and you mentioned it's not helpful
to predict or recommend the things that
people have art that they've already
done because that's not novel to them
but you really need to focus on
where's the types of predictions that
you want to make whether it's on people
you haven't seen before or people that
are activities that they haven't done
before or that that's a very easy type
of evaluation that I think we're all
biased towards because of the
availability to us to predict what's
happening in the next time step where we
actually then can see the next time step
we can see the activity I think what we
need to move to towards is something
that is maybe more like a reinforcement
learning kind of environment where what
we're really looking to do is maximize
some longer-term reward or behavior and
trying to quantify what that is and as
we move towards that and maybe we can
use Chris's type of manual labeling or
labeling rules to get to what those
rewards are in a low-cost kind of
environment I think that's where we need
to be moving towards as a field whether
you're saying that you're working on
prediction or recommendation had two
comments that one is on the
reinforcement learning front things like
the grade scenario is a great case of it
and also just who determines what the
metrics are so in the current setting in
in Purdue it was the faculty and staff
deciding what was in the best interest
of the students and even the likelihood
that a student executes on something if
you elicit from them the goals we know
from social science literature they're
more likely to act on those schools just
be the fact that that you elicited it
from them right so how do you bring
those two together from a design point
and what's going on I think in terms of
the breakfast community it would be
great to engage them further
I actually know several people who are
trying to bring this type of work to the
rexes community so I'm happy to take
that discussion offline with you Peter
so last question and I think we have to
wrap up here question yes
yes I just for the recording purposes
it's useful Luci ports and University of
Minnesota so this is a question for
Chris so it all went by very fast I
promise I'll go try to read but quickly
were you suggesting that the weak
supervision that you're putting forth
with snorkle do you actually get an
uncertainty on the models the excellent
question so I did go through that part
relatively quickly we do actually
estimate a full graphical model pairwise
interactions are typically what's done
in practice you do need a fair number of
views of the correlations to be able to
do that but you have at the end of that
estimation without label data a
distribution now you know what are the
sort of downstream uses of sampling from
that graphical model instead of using
the marginals and what is the benefit of
using the higher-order interactions
we've seen it in some cases one case
which was just recently in a nature
comps paper was if you start to have
really long-range spatial or temporal
correlations and kind of obviously those
higher-level interactions that you're
seeing inside you know you have a
labeling function that's at one frame of
a video versus that 10 frames or you
know what it where's where's the patient
coming from those spans of correlations
indeed are quite meaningful in being
able to categorize video in this case it
was looking at MRIs of hearts and being
able to diagnose a rare semi rare a
aortic problem so that's when those
correlations are there in general and
the first versions of the system even
though we have this this kind of
beautiful graphical model that's laying
there with all the parameters that you
would want even feature eyes we
generally only kind of get the marginals
out of it or run a kind of simple
Junction tree on it but the distribution
is there so it's a really interesting
question what does that uncertainty
quantification actually tell you and
when is it behaving well or poorly yeah
and also as a diagnostic when is it
behaving well or poorly there's clearly
information in that we just haven't
exploited in any way it's a great
question all right let's think all the
speakers again
you